I used to have this fantasy when I would
watch YouTube a trump I was saying to
myself I wish you would take out a map
and say Donald point to where Russia is
I had this fantasy I wanted to to see
you do I wanted you to say name the
president of you slob I just wanted you
know what I mean yeah I wonder if he
could find Texas on the map no well
apparently not because remember he said
the wall was gonna be along Colorado the
problem you know Howard that's a really
interesting insight because I kept
thinking okay we're gonna get to the
debates and I've watched presidential
debates and and you can see moments when
oh my gosh the audience goes you can
just tell right and so I thought okay he
won't be prepared he won't know he'll
just stick with those Sam stick look by
you know all these measurements that
they do I won these debates but it no
longer matters as much and does that's
what bothers me is like okay you were
almost too nice well you know I don't
know if I was too nice but I was
certainly you know very careful and the
reason is look I grew up at a time when
if if you were gonna get through a door
as a woman you did not react to anything
you know I remember taking the law
school exam at a huge hall at Harvard
and there were you know hundreds of men
and there was like maybe 50 women and we
were in this room waiting for the test
to start and I was sitting with some my
women friends who were there with me and
all of a sudden these young men start
harassing us like what are you doing
here you have no right to be here and it
was really it yeah and it was during the
Vietnam War so they were saying things
like if you get a slot then I'm gonna
get sent to Vietnam I'm gonna die it's
gonna be your fault and I mean just guys
say that to saying it they were saying
it to us and so what did we all we just
put our head down like okay yet take the
test you sure you can do it and so
throughout a lot of my both professional
and public career part of it was that
training like okay you're a woman trying
to do something that not many other
women or any women have ever done
you've gotta stay focused don't get
distracted guys are gonna be trying to
say this and and do that you just keep
going and so I understand that in a way
that works to your detriment because
being reverential to even this guy who's
looming behind you on the stage yeah
because if you tap oh and I thought a
lot about this afterwards suppose I had
turned around and said you know back up
you creep you're not gonna intimidate me
the headlines would have been lost her
you know calm you know chess switches
into being angry right it would have
worked again it would have worked
against me and then the you know and
then the you know all the pundits would
have said well she can't take Donald
Trump house you're gonna take Vladimir
Putin so I I'm not unaware of that
you've got this dialogue going on in
your head back and forth